hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast beyond the hype the evidence
behind the role of genetics and drug
response I'm Cristina jewel of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational seminar is
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning we have a few important
announcements people we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you could submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can emerge this flight window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
now if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or you can submit your problem
through the green Q&A button on the
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the c/e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Matt Nelson Matt Nelson is the head of
genetics at GSK working in philadelphia
pennsylvania leading a group of
scientists to bring genetic evidence
into both drug discovery and drug
development decisions research
activities of interest include
investigating the role of the growing
body genome-wide Association studies to
inform drug target selection and
validation improving pharmacogenetics
experiment design and developing methods
and strategies for drawing inferences
from both small and large scale genetic
association studies other recent
activities include analysis
ab deep resequenced data for target
validation development of the pop res
genetic resource for pharmacogenetics
research and co-chair of the scientific
management committee of the cross
industry international serious adverse
event consortium is aec mouse path to
research in the pharmaceutical industry
began at the University of Michigan
where he received degrees and statistics
and Human Genetics with an emphasis on
novel comic combinatorial strategies for
identifying gene by Gene interaction
upon graduation he worked to startup
biopharmaceutical company Experian
therapeutics for three years at a Sperry
on his activities included
cheminformatics preclinical and clinical
study design and analysis development of
online analysis and reporting tools and
leading the Information Systems Group
Matt joined Sequenom a SAN diego-based
biotechnology company in early 2000 to a
director of biostatistics well he was
involved in some of the earliest
attempts at genome-wide Association
studies matt has been with GSK since
2005 with prior roles as a researcher
and ahead of statistical genetics I
would now like to turn the presentation
to over over to dr. Matt Nelson dr.
Nelson Thank You Christy it's a pleasure
to be a part of this virtual event
around precision medicine talking about
the current evidence for the role of
genetics in drug response both in terms
of safety and the efficacy so I'm going
to start out this presentation with a
little bit of background on genetics
research this is going to be very
superficial I'm not going to go very
deep given the time constraint we have
in the the other material that I hope to
be able to cover I'll give you a little
bit of a glimpse in terms of what were
some of the early hints that genes could
play a really important role and how we
respond to some drugs and the series of
research activities that that has led to
fall from the perspective of
understanding drug safe
as well as understanding drug efficacy
and I'll finish that off by discussing
the implications that this research has
had for our own research activities
within GSK a drug a drug discovery and
development company and how we
incorporate genetics into our routine
drug development activity great so first
of genetics background so genetics is
the study of heredity it's the study of
how the genetic characteristics that we
inherit from our mother and our Father
influence the way that that we respond
to the world around us from a phenotypic
perspective so going back to your high
school and college genetics course of
course you know that there are 23
chromosome pairs we inherit one copy
from our mother one copy from our from
our father every single cell in our body
every live cell in our body has a full
complement of these of these pairs there
are 6 billion bases in our in our
genetic material within each cell it's
truly remarkable you if you were to take
the the genetic material out of one cell
and unwound it it would be roughly a
meter long but of course that gets
packed into submicroscopic level inside
of inside of each of ourselves within
that DNA codes for about 20,000
so-called genes these are stretches of
DNA that code for the proteins that are
so integral in in our biology and in who
we are now although if you compared any
two individuals we roughly have the same
DNA there are a lot of differences from
person to person across our our DNA
that's what gives rise to to genetic
variation and inherit ability of our
individual traits there are roughly 10
million relatively common single
nucleotide changes we call their
nucleotide polymorphisms across our DNA
and there are many many more very rare
variants there are other kinds of
variants that we inherit one type is
called an in Dell or an insertion
deletion these are relatively small one
to say 15 base deletions of those
letters that make up our DNA there are
also more complex changes as well they
can be very large solutions of anywhere
from a hundred basis to hundreds of
thousands or even millions of bases or
rearrangements with those DNA all of
those give rise to differences in our
individual characteristics just to
remind you this is the canonical cartoon
of a of a gene you have a relatively
long chromosome a stretch of DNA within
that chromosome you can identify regions
of that DNA that code portions of
proteins so in this cartoon we have four
protein coding portions that contribute
to gnex we call those protein coding
portions that are shown here and get my
annotator out there shown here those are
called X on the segments of DNA that
separate the exons are called introns
and so if you zoom in on any section of
that gene you could see it doesn't
actually look like letters but we use
the letters to represent the chemical
building blocks that make up our DNA and
again so these represent a single
nucleotide polymorphism change that may
occur at any one of these bases that it
gives rise to to the genetic differences
amongst us and those genetic differences
we can actually measure and there are a
wide variety of different laboratory
techniques from techniques that use
silicone based chips to techniques that
that actually go in and sequence each
individual base
where we can we can measure the those
underlying genetic characteristics in
each person in our sample and we can
take those underlying genetic
characteristics and we can relate them
to differences among individuals so here
I'm showing an example that we'll come
back to in a minute but on the y-axis
here of this plot we have the dose of
warfarin that patients have received and
across the x-axis here we have different
genotypes and again these genotypes are
referenced as two bases because one base
you get from your mother and the one
from your father so we have some
individuals that are TT some individuals
at RTC and some individuals that are CC
and in this particular instance we find
that there's a relatively large effect
of that genotype on the dose of warfarin
that a person ends up on once they have
been titrated to the proper dose this is
one of the first discoveries that we've
that we had early on in pharmacogenetics
and that's the vitamin K receptor for
warfarin and we found that that
differences at the site had a relatively
big impact on the the ultimate dose that
a person would settle on so again we can
measure genetic variation in a large
number of way during modern channels
that are used today can measure anywhere
from three hundred thousand to a million
of the single nucleotide polymorphisms
they can measure thousands of insertion
deletion and we can use those measures
to carry out studies like I was showing
in the previous slide all the way across
the genome and we refer to those studies
as genome-wide Association study and so
in each of those studies we we can look
at every single one of those variants
and ask is that variant related to the
disease or to the characteristic that
we're interested in studying you don't
have to rely on panels we actually have
the capability now to sequence either
the entire exome which is a word that
just refers to the coding portions of
our genome or even the entire genome in
one fell swoop
revealing tens of thousands of genetic
variants at the individual level that we
can then study so the our capability to
to delve into to measure our genetic
material and then to relate those
differences in our genetic material to
our various characteristics is has just
been transformed in revolutionized over
the past 10 years as the technologies
for doing this have developed what I'm
showing here is the discoveries that
have been made using that type of
genetic technology and if you can see
the x-axis here the the scale that can
only point er here so across the x-axis
only area are across the x-axis are we
have dates and we're essentially showing
the accumulation of these discoveries of
how our genetic variant influence our
traits over the past roughly 12 years of
discovery on the y-axis is the number of
discovery that has been reported and
these are coming from a catalog that
i'll show you in just a moment but you
can see that back in 2005 there were
very very few
I can I yes so here
in 2005 there were just a very small
handful maybe 10 to 20 of these genetic
variants that were influencing even
traits that we had actually been able to
discover and validate you can see that
starting in roughly 2007 the pace of
those discoveries began to pick up quite
dramatically and this coincides with the
development of the technologies to be
able to measure human genetic variation
at the such a large scale and conducting
these genome-wide Association studies
the pace continue to go up quite rapidly
that increased pace was partly
influenced by further improvements in
technology and what we could measure but
the main advancement in those
discoveries was around the size of the
studies that we carry out as we carried
out larger and larger studies more and
more cases more and more controls to to
identify what our genetics is
influencing our traits we found more and
more under the hood more and more of
those individual genetic variants that
are having an impact on on so many
different characteristics you can
actually go out and query those those
discoveries yourself there is a site on
the internet called G wash catalogue
this is hosted by the European
bioinformatics Institute ebi after it
was transferred there from the United
States NHGRI the National Human Genome
Research Institute and you can type in
any gene that you're interested in
renting or any disease that you're
interested in and you could identify all
of the different genetic variants that
have been discovered to to be involved
in that disease so here's a little
example of the kind of query results you
could get so I've inserted here a drug
response phenotype liver injury and by
typing that in I found that there were
several publications for several
different drugs where they had
investigated the genetic impact on on on
the liver injury phenotype and you can
see that for each of these
they down here in this last column
indicates the number of discoveries
underlying each of those if you were to
do this you could click on the little
plus there on the floor right and you
can explore those in greater detail to
find where in the genome those
discoveries were found okay so that's a
little bit of background on genetics so
let me get back to to the topic at hand
and that's pharmacogenetics
pharmacogenetics is a simply a term that
refers to the genetics of drug response
third response can be described in terms
of drug exposure how much drug we we get
in our system when we when we take a
prescribed dose it can refer to drug
safety adverse reactions such as liver
injury it can also refer to drug
efficacy how well do we respond to a
drug when we receive it genetics has
been shown to have some influence in all
of those and that we collectively refer
to the study of these three things as as
pharmacogenetics some of the genetics is
not a recent discovery or phenomenon
actually the first publication for
pharmacogenetics was published by the
famed geneticist are Emma tolsky in 1957
where he described protein differences
in g6pd and the impact that that had on
anemia and anti-malarial response so so
pharmacogenetics is not at all a new
science I showed you earlier the one of
the early ethicacy pharmacogenetics
discoveries and that is the influence of
this genetic variant in the vitamin K
receptor on on warfarin response and
essentially the the dose that is that a
person that eventually is prescribed
when you titrate to a particular
response coagulation response in the
blood is strongly influenced by by
variance in the vitamin K receptor so
what this is this background and you
know so this despite mu k receptor
association
was discovered in in 2005 there were a
lot of expectations that that genetics
would be applied to two drug response
and that we would find right and left
these big genetic factors that would
help us to identify just which patients
a drug will be safe and effective in and
this was particularly of interest
because we've seen over the years that
that drug discovery and drug development
is very hard this pie chart on the right
shows the reasons why drugs fail in
phase 3 and and we know of course that
that roughly fifty percent of all drugs
in phase three do fail face through
clinical trials and don't progress to to
registration and the primary explanation
for these failures are due to lack of
efficacy sixty-four percent and
insufficient safety twenty-seven percent
so an ability to to use genetics to
better differentiate the best patients
to receive a drug could potentially have
a very big impact on on drug discovery
and development and ultimately on
ensuring that patients are getting the
right treatments also around that time
in 2001 this is actually a back of yer
as a drug that GSK developed for
treatment of HIV and we have found
during drug during the drug development
in clinical trials that up to five
percent of patients that received a back
of ear would experience a
hypersensitivity reaction and that
hypersensitivity reaction could be quite
severe and if a patient continue to
receive the drug or was reach Allan JH
twith the drug that that reaction could
potentially be life-threatening so there
was a whole series of mitigation
strategies that were put into place to
be able to identify very early signs of
these reactions and to withdraw patients
from from a back of your if they were if
they were seeing that well we started
applying out
were our genetics tools as crude and
rudimentary as they were back in in two
thousand to see if we couldn't identify
genetic factors that might differentiate
the patients the five percent of
patients that received the drug and
demonstrate some sort of
hypersensitivity reaction from the
ninety-five percent that received the
drug and never experienced any type of
negative adverse event and lo and behold
what we found was that a portion of our
genome the HLA region that encodes the
proteins that are involved in our
adaptive immune response a particular
version of the HLA be gene called 5701
was actually very strongly associated
with these hypersensitivity reactions
and that's what's shown here in this in
this table in the first publication
describing this with just 84 cases and
113 controls we see that those that had
hla-b 57 were much more likely to
experience the adverse event than those
that did not carry actually be fixed
2701 so GSK set out to to definitively
demonstrate the role of B 5701 in an
hypersensitivity reaction through a pair
of clinical trials that were carried out
one of these clinical trials was called
predict one predict one study design we
took patients that had HIV that had
never received a back of year before
here referred to as ABC or Rebecca Vere
naive subjects and they were either
randomized to the standard of care which
is to prescribe a Kabir and to follow
the patient's very carefully with
drawing them if they show any symptoms
of hypersensitivity reaction and in the
other arm in equal numbers we carried
out a pharmacogenetics screen and we
remove patients from the clinical trial
that carried the B 5701 allele that were
positive for that allele and we only
gave the drug to patients that that did
not carry that that risk factor
is also the predict one trial were
published in 2008 and the results were
overwhelmingly positive what we found
was in particular when we looked at
patients that had a skin patch test that
was a objective confirmation that they
were experienced a hypersensitivity to a
back of ear we found that in the arm in
which no patients carrying be 5701
received a vaca beer there were no event
of hypersensitivity reaction in the
other arm where they were randomized to
the standard of care we found that only
patients carrying be 5701 experienced
and immunologically a skin patch test
confirmed hypersensitivity reaction so
this test we found was was a hundred
percent predictive of a being able to
take a vaca V R safely so again this
came relatively early on in our
understanding of genetics in android
response and so there was tremendous
optimism and enthusiasm that we would be
able to explain away most negative
effects to drugs through application of
genetics and in the instance of the back
of air this this test made it into the
drug label and n census had a an
important role in the use of the back of
your in treating patients with HIV so so
what have we learned since then has has
genetic spin this treasure trove of
information about how patients are going
to respond adversely to drugs and is it
having a big impact in the clinic so
this table here comes from a publication
that came out I was a first author on in
2009 that summarized what was the state
of the field in in 2007 roughly around
the time that this missive a cover story
was was coming out and there were very
very few such discoveries at that time
and actually looking across this list
there are a few of these discoveries
that probably don't really really hold
up well we within gfk and really across
the industry and and in academia as well
we're quite enthusiastic about this as a
as a strategy for improving overall
safety of drugs we thought is
essentially a call to action in 2007 we
knew that genetics could play an
important role in serious adverse events
such as the back of your
hypersensitivity we knew that collecting
cases and studying genetics especially
at that time was that was expensive and
challenging we didn't know what the best
methodologies for studying serious
adverse events with genetics would be
but we knew that it was in everyone's
common interest to study this as
thoroughly and effectively as possible
so there were ten different
pharmaceutical companies and several
public and academic groups that came
together under the international serious
adverse events consortium with the goal
of understanding the mission to identify
DNA variants useful understanding the
risk of drug-induced serious adverse
events and ultimately in in being able
to predict those patients that would
likely experience a serious adverse
event a big emphasis of this consortium
was to pull both the commercial and
academic resources to be able to
identify the cases of the serious and
generally very rare adverse event so
that we can study them sufficiently and
develop the methodology around that that
research the initial focus and primary
focus of the FAC shown here
primarily around liver injury skin
injury including hypersensitivity
reactions is an affiliate and systemic
symptoms renal injury torsades de pont
as well as several inflammatory bowel
disease therapy-related SI es that that
are observed we also were able to
opportunistically investigate a number
of other conditions including
osteonecrosis of the jaw excessive
weight gain due to atypical
antipsychotics and even close the pain
induced agranulocytosis as i said an
important part of this cross academic
commercial consortium was just bringing
all of the researchers together
necessary to identify large enough large
enough numbers of serious adverse event
cases to be able to study them from a
genetic perspective and what's important
to note that for example liver injury
there are literally hundreds of drugs
that are reported to potentially have
some impact on on liver safety on liver
and so to be able to get enough cases of
drug specific events it really takes
this type of international consortium to
carry it out and this table here
summarizes the the success that we
achieved in doing that we had almost
over 2,500 liver injury cases we had
nearly 1500 serious skin reaction cases
and then you can see that the numbers
amongst these others so all in all the
serious adverse event consortium was
instrumental in bringing together over
7,000 nearly 8,000 cases of these
various serious adverse events
i'm going to show you now a couple of
discoveries that kind of help illustrate
how we do this research as well as the
kinds of results for this research what
I'm showing you on this slide was our
very first publication in 2009 are
really our first success that came from
this consortium and this is a the result
of Ag was--or a genome-wide Association
study for two o'clock Sicilian liver
injury Brooks oxacillin is an antibiotic
it has an incidence of liver injury
sometimes very serious liver injury of
approximately 1 in 5,000 cases and we
were able to very early in the
consortium's life bring together over 50
cases of the serious adverse event and
we with those 50 cases and a large
number of of controls we measured them
genome-wide so we had roughly a million
genetic variants that we have able to
measure in these patients and for each
one of those million variants we carry
out an analysis of whether that variant
was associated with the risk of liver
injury due to flip oxacillin so across
the x-axis in this figure which is often
referred to as a Manhattan plot we have
the location of each of those million
variants that we tested from chromosome
one up through chromosome X and the
height of each of these points is the p
value or the statistical significance of
the relationship between each variant
and the risk of liver injury to the
flucloxacillin now if you're used to
running kind of your traditional
statistical tests one hypothesis at a
time you may recall that the approach is
to pick some p-value threshold that
would lead you to make a good choice as
to whether to reject the null hypothesis
and traditionally for a single test that
value would be on the order of about
point zero five or maybe point zero one
or you're going to be really stringent
point zero zero one
well that's fine if you're only
conducting one test but if you're
conducting a million tests you have to
be much more careful about how you guard
yourself from making a type one error
and that is rejecting the null
hypothesis one in fact it is true and so
you have to use much more stringent
statistical criteria so for a
traditional genome-wide Association
study we would be using thresholds on
the order of about 10 to the negative 8
so about right here for drawing our
conclusions it's roughly at 10 to the
negative 8 so p value that has a point
zero well seven zeros and followed by a
1 after it and you can clearly see that
there is only one region of the genome
that exceeds that threshold and it
exceeds that threshold by far we have P
values that are deterred in around 10 to
the negative 35 that peak that that
comes up here and there is only one peak
from this association falls under the
HLA region of the genome this is the
same region that we saw previously
associated with the back of your
hypersensitivity reaction and lo and
behold it actually turns out to be the
exact same the exact same genetic
variant that is hleb 5701 underlying
successful in liver injury
so so that was our first discovery in
that area our next discovery was also in
liver injury and that was for
co-amoxiclav or amoxicillin clavulanic
acid which here in the United States is
is referred to as augmentin so this
augmentin jiwa Segen so you're seeing a
very similar Manhattan plot for this and
you're also seeing a relatively similar
pattern and that is that we don't have
very many p values that get small or
reach that genome-wide significant
threshold of 10 to the negative 8 except
in the HLA region what was interesting
about the augmentin liver injury study
was that when we zoomed in on that
region of the HLA what we actually found
there were two independent peaks of
Association one peak over here on the
Left associated with class 1 HLA
molecules and this region over here on
our right associated with class to hla
molecules so again we find that HLAs is
playing a pretty important role well
we've carried out really hundreds of
such analyses looking at different types
of serious adverse events with and the
risk provided by different drugs and I
won't bore you with with each of those
but what I will do is summarize for you
essentially where the field of genetic
influence on adverse event is today so I
showed you a few slides back where we
were in 2007 well this is a similar
slide showing where we are today on the
left are the discoveries or the they're
grouped into different types of adverse
events liver injury skin injury some of
these other had sensitivity reactions
and then just a catch-all for everything
else these are the discoveries that were
made outside of the serious adverse
event consortium so some of these from
GSK some of these from from other
pharmaceutical companies or or academic
researchers on the right or the
discoveries that have resulted from the
consolidated efforts of the serious
adverse events consortium
just focusing on a couple of key
messages from the slide one of the key
messages is the kinds of associations
that we're observing so the
association's shown in red are those
that were localized to the HLA locus so
these are immune response related
adverse event the ones in green
correspond to genes that are involved in
drug metabolism the absorption
distribution metabolism and excretion of
a drug so one of the key patterns that
you can see based on these relatively
well validated discoveries to date is
that all of these associations fall into
one of those two classes either HLA or
or add me the other point to make is
that the serious adverse events
consortium has been quite productive in
terms of the discovery of a very large
fraction of the total discoveries that
that we've had to date in this area
questions you might ask is if you're
familiar with with some of the
limitations of genome-wide Association
studies well genome-wide Association
studies are generally limited to
investigating relatively common genetic
variants but the genetic variants
underline or well the most of these
serious adverse events are quite rare so
is it possible that there are also very
rare genetic variant that might be
underlying these rare adverse events so
the serious adverse event consortium has
looked at three different adverse events
in some detail where we didn't just use
genetic markers across the genome but
where we actually went down and
sequenced at the variant level the
participants in these studies and what
we found well so that the three studies
we carry out were augmentin liver injury
the clozapine induced agranulocytosis
and enter sod deep want and really the
bottom line there is so far we have not
found that that rare genetic variants
are primarily responsible for those rare
adverse events but but rather that we're
finding relatively common variants that
that are involved another lesson that
we've learned as we've elucidated the
growing number of genetic risk factors
for for some of these serious adverse
event is that again the genetic risk
factors tend to be relatively common
whereas the adverse events tend to be
relatively rare so I'm circling here the
frequency of the variants that we
discovered in these populations they
range from anywhere from from one
percent sometimes a little bit smaller
than one percent as low as 100 two
percent or point two percent up to up to
about thirty percent while these
variants can have relatively large
effect
they don't tend to be very predictive
that is that the vast majority of
patients who carry those variants can
take the drug and will never experience
that adverse event so whereas for
example I showed before a back of your
roughly fifty percent of the patients
that carry be 5701 if they receive the
back of ear would end up having that
adverse drug reaction for the other
kinds of discoveries that we found so
far to date most of them look a bit like
this that is that because the adverse
events are so rare the vast majority of
the patients they carry these genetic
risk factors even taking the drug will
never develop them it's even more
challenging when you look at the
negative predictive value again we found
that essentially the the negative
predictive value or 1 minus negative
predictive value for the back of ear was
was was zero that is those that didn't
carry the risk allele would never
develop the adverse drug reaction for
the other drugs and risk factors that
we've identified the the genetic marker
doesn't do that good of a job of
differentiating those who would go on to
to develop the the adverse reaction
versus those that won't on that topic I
want to introduce you to a very valuable
resource this is the clinical
pharmacogenetics implementation
consortium I have the the website for it
down here in the lower left-hand corner
the goal of obscene pick is to
essentially look at the evidence of
healthcare for each of the drugs and the
genetic variants that are associated
with those adverse events and assess
what impact those might have clinically
and if you go to that website you can
find 33 published guidelines that that
provide a summary of the science
underlying each of those associations as
well as clinical recommendations for
them and that really is i think the
single best resource that i could point
you to if you want to have a better
understanding of whether they're arjun
factors that might have an impact in in
a particular drug that you are
interested in prescribing and
potentially considering a genetic test
for so what have we learned so far let
me go through this quite quickly the
mechanisms underlying the genetics of
serious adverse events are largely
limited to hla and admin these for
metabolizing gene common variants with a
significant impact on the risk of
serious adverse event can be identified
with relatively small numbers of cases
as few or even smaller than 50 using
these genome-wide approaches what we
find is that most of the HLA genetic
risk factors are fairly drug specific
although we do see some commonality Park
can be 5701 that we saw for both the
back of ear and fook oxacillin the HLA
risk factors appear to be fairly serious
adverse event specific for for a given
drug and as I mentioned previous I'd
common genetic risk factors alone don't
accurately predict patient risk for rare
SAE and as such there aren't many
instances where prospective typing is
going to be justified when making a
decision about which drug patients
should receive and the serious adverse
events for many drugs really more than
fifty percent don't appear to have a
major genetic risk factor so we we don't
expect genetics to explain much of the
risk for for most drugs so let me change
gears one more time and talk about the
role of genetics and drug efficacy so
I'm going to to to tell the story let me
take you back to two GSK's experience
GSK has been conducting pharmacogenetics
research within our clinical trials and
even post clinical trials for the
marketed medicine since the days of back
of your hypersensitivity reaction we've
carried out several dozen
pharmacogenetic studies of various drugs
for football truck safety and drug
efficacy
and here's what we've discovered over
the years we have the back of your
discovery tryna left and the effect of
ugt1a1 on bilirubin we found that a
genetic factor affecting bilirubin in
prison abbr drug-induced liver injury
for lapatinib and drug aloof
drug-induced liver injury four paws off
in it all of these five discoveries that
we've had within GSK to date our safety
related as we saw these patterns emerged
we asked ourselves does genetics really
have a role to play in safety
pharmacogenetics and is that well
important enough that we would
incorporate that into our our clinical
development activities so to ask that
question we both looked quite carefully
at the work that we had done previously
but primarily we look outside we asked
how many examples are there out there of
efficacy effects genetic efficacy
effects on drugs what can we learn from
those examples and how should we go
about finding them and these results
were published just this past year and
make sure reviews genetics which which I
can refer to you too if you'd like to
get more details about that work let me
just summarize one of the key studies
and outcomes from that and waiting for
that slide to come up a little bit of a
delay here
area okay so to carry out this study we
went back to that G watch catalog that I
told you about before and the the study
that we published had data in the
catalog as recent as July of 2015 so
there were roughly 2,200 distinct
genome-wide Association study reports in
the catalog we filtered those 2,200 down
to those that were related to drug
efficacy of which there were 76 so
roughly three point four percent of the
catalog entries so 76 Angie wasco
responded to 1441 different drugs and
drug classes or combinations and of
those we filtered it down to those that
had a very strong statistical evidence
underlying that that association and so
of those we found 13 gos genome-wide
Association studies with drug efficacy
that had one or more high confidence
associations that is only about fifteen
percent six out of 41 of the drugs for
which there was a genome-wide
Association study for drug efficacy did
we actually find a convincing
Association
so what were what underlies those those
reported association so they're shown
here they actually correspond to only
six distinct drugs or drug classes more
frankel put agreable reserved you satiny
other statins metformin and peg
interferon the the efficacy measured
that that underlies that each of those
shown here in the second column and the
third column shows the the genes that
have been identified as the likely
culprit underlying those genetic
associations I'd asterisk the the entry
here where there is a see pic treatment
guidance available in the feet pic
resource I mentioned before and that's
corresponds to warfarin cope integral
and MPEG interferon so of all of the 76
g wasthat were carried out these are the
only 13 associations that we were able
to identify from those studies and again
those only correspond to six distinct
drugs or drug classes several of those
associations had actually been
identified in the pre jiwa fara through
candidate gene studies for example the
vitamin K receptor Association that I
had described before was actually
discovered not through these genome-wide
methods but but through Canada gene
analysis we spend our search not just to
those discovers Georgie wasps but also
to those that have been identified
through these types of candidate gene
studies but but for nonetheless fairly
convincing and their evidence underlying
them and I'm showing these associations
here you have codeine tamoxifen neck
ilysm AB the entire some kinase
inhibitors platinum-based chemotherapy
elaborate and sulfa areas and then these
are the genes that have been associated
with those
so let me just take a couple of minutes
to summarize what we found with on the
Ithaca genetics efficacy genetic side we
found three different types of genes
that were that tended to be involved
genes involved in add me again the drug
absorption and metabolism excretion
genes involved in the the function of
the the drug so the drug target itself
such as the vitamin K receptor and genes
involved into these mechanisms so the
disease much more broadly as as
illustrated here
interestingly of those discoveries 74 74
percent of the discoveries came about
when there was a continuous biomarker
that measured the response so something
that was relatively sensitive and
relatively objective and measuring how
well a patient is doing when they're on
the drug so we found that as is quite
telling from a study design perspective
and how we want to go about pursuing
identifying these in the future that
we're much more likely to be able to
identify them when we have a measure
that's very sensitive to to response as
opposed to a clinical assessment of
responder vs vs non responder in the
interest of time I'm going to skip this
relatively complicated slide and go on
to one of the key outcomes from the
study that we published and now we've to
get a sense of well how often how many
drugs do we think are likely to have
genetic factors that influence efficacy
that could be large enough that they
could impact clinical decision making
and so we took essentially our estimate
of what proportion of gos were able to
find a genetic effect underlying it the
proportion of those known genetic
factors that are large enough that it's
likely to have clinical impact which is
roughly sixty four percent and then came
up with this estimate that roughly ten
percent or so of drugs are likely to
have genetic factors that are large
enough that they can be discovered and
could potentially influence patient
outcomes so so that's our expectation
going into this that only about ten
percent of drugs are are likely to
benefit from genetic information in
making decisions about which patients
should receive it from furman efficacy
perspective
I'm going to skip this also just out of
the interest of time so some of the
lessons that we've that we've drawn from
our our efficacy genetics assessment
that there are we need to recognize that
when we're searching genome-wide that by
conducting a very large number of tests
we're going to adversely affect our
statistical power to identify those
genetic associations so if we can reduce
the number of tests we carry out to a
smaller number we will increase our
power to find them and given that the
mechanisms underlying both safety and
efficacy effects are limited to a
relatively small number of genes in the
genome at least that we've discovered
date then focusing primarily on those
those mechanisms and modalities are
likely to to improve our success rates
we find that there are very few
situations where pharmacogenetics is
large enough that that you would
actually find it in a clinical trial and
that it would rescue a failed trial of
child it didn't have a large enough drug
effect to to be able to differentiate
the the treatment arms in the trial
trials with larger artifacts are going
to have more power to find efficacy
pharmacogenetics so this is a bit
counterintuitive related to the previous
point and that is that that we're going
to have the most success in finding
genetic factors when drugs are really
effective of course if they're effective
for everyone then then we don't
necessarily need genetics but that's not
usually the case even very effective
drugs often have large sub groups that
don't respond particularly well and if
we're conducting this and in a clinical
trial setting we really do need to
combine data across trials to increase
our statistical power to to identify
them
so just to recap implications on drug
development we expect about ten percent
of drugs to have genetic predictors of
drug efficacy that it can that could
influence clinical decision making right
now is a relatively low cost of
pharmacogenetic analysis does justify in
many instances very early and more
routine screening for genetic factors
even in clinical development and phase 2
and phase 3 clinical trials and that
there are a number of things as I
discussed in the previous slide that we
can do to improve our probability of
success and tailoring our analysis
strategies to identify those factors so
and you know I think that I've made all
of the key points for this presentation
in any previous slide so I'm going to
the slide you're going to be provided to
to the participants in this I'm going to
skip over my last couple of slides you
can find essentially a a short summary
of our overall observations of the role
of genetics and drug exposure truck
safety and drug efficacy in this slide
and I will just finish by highlighting
the the many people that have
contributed to the work that I've
presented today both for the serious
adverse events consortium and drug
safety as well as my colleagues here
within GSK and the books we've done
around drug efficacy thank you
thank you dr. Nelson for that
informative presentation now before we
get started on our Q&A session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit the
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can but
if by chance were unable to get to your
questions due to time constraints dr.
Nelson will be answering questions via
email following the presentation okay
dr. Nelson our first question is how
many significant genetic variants are
found in a typical jiwa is it different
for studies of diseases versus drug
response yeah that's a really good
question so the examples that I showed
here today there were very few s'okay
for example is phu quoc sicilian g wasps
or the augmentin g wasps really found
just one major peak of association
around HLA for most complex diseases
particularly when we are able to expand
those out in two very large samples of
cases and controls we typically find
that there are dozens and sometimes
hundreds of genetic low sites that are
influencing these various diseases that
we study I imagine that if we were able
to carry out a drug response g wasps
with tens of thousands of patients who
had taken the drug and we were able to
measure very well how they were
responding to those drugs we would
probably find many many more genetic
associations than what we're finding in
the kinds of studies we can carry today
we're we're we're limited to a
relatively small number of patients so I
don't know if if that means that that
the underlying genetic architecture for
drug response is that different than
disease or if it's just that we don't
yet have the the sample sizes and
statistical power to to be able to find
many of the very small
subtle effects that might be having
relatively small impacts on drug
response but that's the that's a
question that hopefully one day we will
be able to answer particularly as
genetic data becomes more routine as
part of a medical record and we may have
the opportunity to combine both routine
genetic data with large electronic
health records to be able to search for
those on a very large scale
now dr. Nelson the serious adverse
events consortium looks like it has been
pretty productive is it still running
study yeah so the serious adverse event
consortium was initiated in 2007
initially with a three-year phase one in
2010 we decided to extend the consortium
for an additional three years through
very careful and use of its of its
funding the consortium has continued to
to function right now we are in
essentially the the sunset years of the
consortium there there are no new funds
coming in for consortium research but we
do have sufficient funds to wrap up the
the the research that we started the the
main body of work going on right now is
finishing up some expensive work around
liver injury around renal injury as well
as conducting a bit more research
looking across different types of
serious adverse event as well as across
drugs but but that that work will be
wrapping up likely within the next six
to 12 months now dr. Nelson in your
presentation you briefly mentioned that
pharmacogenetics is unlikely to rescue a
failed clinical trial can you clarify
what you meant by that yes so and I'm
there specifically referring to trials
that fail because the drug just didn't
have enough efficacy we weren't able to
differentiate the effect of the drug
versus whatever the standard of care was
whether it's placebo or or or some other
treatment so the idea behind that is
that if and Kaline can check water all
right the idea behind that is this is if
there's not a large enough average
effect they're most likely won't be
enough patients with in that trial
experiencing a sufficient effect that
even if there was a genetic
or some other biomarker that could
differentiate those patients from the
rest that you would actually be able to
discover that in a in a clinical trial
that's coming back to that paradox that
I mentioned earlier when I was
introducing that and that is it that we
actually have the greatest capacity to
find those factors that differentiate
patients that respond really well versus
not so well when a drug is really
effective and when when a drug is
ineffective there's just a very small
number of situations where you could
particularly in an exploratory setting
where you don't know the factors that
may be differentiating drug response to
actually go in and explore and search
and find them so that's that's
essentially what I meant by that okay
thank you for that clarification now we
are almost at a time we'd have time for
one last question but again to our
audience dr. Nelson will be replying to
questions via email post the
presentation our final question dr.
Nelson did you expect genetics to play
an important role in the future of
healthcare yeah that's the
million-dollar question my sense is the
answer is yes I think that there are
enough examples and I again referring
back to the sea pick the the
pharmacogenetics guidance that's that's
available there enough positive examples
to tell yes genetics does have a role
the challenge is really in the economics
of it at what point does genetic
information become just a routine part
of a person's medical record because
it's a very different decision to make
when you are going to make a prescribing
decision and you can see what drugs are
likely to be most effective or safest in
that particular patient immediately as
opposed to having to go out and conduct
a laboratory test which sometimes can be
time-consuming they can take several
days or even weeks to get a result back
and they can sometimes be expensive tens
to hundreds of them
lawyers for for those tests so so my
sense is that once genetics becomes a
routine part of our medical care that
that pharmacogenetics will find its
place in routine medical care dr. Nelson
I want to thank you today for your
presentation would you like to say any
final comments to our audience before we
close no thank you to appreciate the
opportunity to present today we
appreciate it and we appreciate you
coming and taking your time out I would
also like to thank our sponsor lab roots
for making today's educational webcast
possible and also a thank you to our
audience for their great participation
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 22nd 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement your
colleagues who may have missed today's
by the event we thank you for joining us
and hope to see you next time goodbye